okay hey everyone it's Michael balos
here and welcome to the orderflows
market analysis for Wednesday May 3rd
2017 there was no change and no surprise
from the Federal Reserve and they held
rate steady and downplayed how slow
first quarter consumer spending was uh
also saying the fundamentals point to a
snapback you know really I I think the
big uh the big surprise was the market
did uh did absolutely nothing you know
usually you got no very little movement
you got move moved a point in the uh
snps and uh maybe five or six uh ticks
in the bonds so um to me that was the
big surprise actually I mean you
normally You' get a little bit more
activity a little bit more volatility in
the market but again you know this is
this is a um this is a big week in terms
of what you got coming out you know the
house passed uh the spending Bill
keeping the government open until like
uh September obviously you got non-farm
payrolls on Friday and you got the
French election on on Sunday and also
you throw in a bunch of boatload of fed
speakers on Friday Janet Yellen speaking
um obviously is the main one but um you
know I was a bit surprised the market
did uh did basically a belly flop in the
sense that it did nothing um but you
know that happens sometimes so again you
know before we get started get through
the disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should be not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
contra contractor make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without shepardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should considered trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results the tools
I'm going to use in this presentation
are mainly the uh orderflows Trader the
footprint chart the Delta scalper and
the Delta surge Delta surge you can
download for free on my website it runs
on ninja Trader 7 and let's uh let's
Jump Right In Here first uh we'll start
with the uh snps the four range chart
and you know there was something a
little bit interesting before the uh you
know the FED announcement but you just
really quick you know 1:00 Chicago time
was the FED announcement and this is it
right here um nothing happened basically
uh very quiet you know compared you know
in the bonds you did get a little bit of
movement where's my bond chart here
dragging it
in here's the bond chart
and looking at uh time 1:00
here this is one this is this is the
announcement so you you got a little bit
of flurry of activity not much you can
just see the thin volumes In These Bars
um you know you're training a couple
hundred 200 400 500 400 400 400
300 before people started coming back
into the market you know and then you're
back up to your normal volumes 1,000
5,000 you know th000 uh 2,000 so anyway
that said I'll talk about bonds a little
bit later but
uh you know for now I'll talk about &ps
real quick
now been a been a a quiet
morning and I this is the wrong that's
that's
my okay you just really
quick you know ninja
Trader 7 you know one of the drawbacks
ninja Traer 7 is you know when you when
you're reading the order flow right when
you you have the software on there it it
reads the data as it comes in the reason
I have this chart open is because you
know someone was saying hey you know my
charts are different than yours is
because you know they open their charts
around at a certain time whereas my
charts are open up um you know much
earlier in the day and and you know as a
result you know I got the data coming in
you know the software reads the data as
it comes in so it doesn't plot the
historical data um you know that was
there I mean it does but it it's not uh
it's not accurate and that that's a
limitation of ninja Trader 7
unfortunately um this is that's why we
want to go back
here you know just really
quick like for example this low that was
here at 8
831 for example this is this chart on
the right is the chart that was
open basically you know from 3: in the
morning so that's why you see this data
is accurate I know this one is not
because I know my chart wasn't open at
this time and it's just it's trying to
read the data properly but it doesn't so
you see 65 on the low 65 you know 2600
here is 21100 or against 8 26 you know
this is 299 that's just a limitation of
ninja Trader 7 but once your chart is
open data is coming in the data is
accurate okay and to be honest when
you're using a footprint
chart you you're not you know when when
it's 10:00 you're not con you're not
concerned with what happened at uh you
know the actual order flow that happened
at 4 in the morning um so you know it's
not necessarily something that you you
need I mean that's why you know people
ask me you know when do you start your
charts well I started you know I used to
keep my software on or my computer on
from Sunday until Saturday or till
Friday night but I've I I've changed it
you know I've I I turned my computer off
for a couple hours at night um so
basically my my computer runs from about
3:00 a.m. Chicago time the data you know
collecting the data from 3:00 a.m. until
until the evening session I I don't put
much uh into the asan session um
especially you know I say especially
yeah I worked in Asia for many years 10
years about and you know I know decent
volume goes through but you know what um
it's
it's 20% if that 10% more likely of the
day volume occurs during the asent
session so you know if if I have to cut
out a time of the day
to you know save data you know it would
be during that session but you know if
you could turn if you keep it on all
week your system you know by all means
do it if you can't you know you'd want
to start it as early as it could in the
European session um so you know that's
that's just a brief a brief
uh thoughts on that so really the big
thing here in the snps this morning was
we had rally you know we had made our
low at this point at 911 a.m. Chicago
time you know at this 2379 level and
started rallying up from it then he got
up here at 82 which was your point of
control for the day at that point
and in the bars you have your point of
controls also lined up there you got
four point of controls right in a
row and you know for
me you how how you look at that is well
you you talk about Market generated
levels this is a market generated level
here you know you've got a resistance
level here or you know if we're going to
be below it you know we came out in this
bar
here this next bar well below it so I'm
thinking you know I'm looking at this
this is going to be my resistance level
if this was a green bar we training
above it this would be my support level
but for now you know we're below it this
is my resistance level I even said it
you know in in the room looking at this
as being my if we come out start trading
lower clearly below it this is going to
be a resistance level and what happens
we you know we finish this bar down at
87 and 3/4 at 80 and 3/4 next bar down
as well so I'm pretty convinced at this
point that this is going to be my
support level so you know if you want to
get short you can definitely be getting
short anywhere you know between 80 and
81 you honestly in this bar here it's
you know when we're training towards the
bottom you know I'm pretty convinced
already that that's going to be holding
when you see this new lower point of
control here and you already got two
bars coming off this level I'm already
convinced that this is a support level
and you know we just you know so if
you're getting short anywhere around
this this 80 level even in this bar here
it's a bit late again it's right off the
low though um you know we trade down we
you know so if you're getting short from
80 uh we get down as low as 752 before
we sort of bounced up again here to 765
77 and you know we got the Delta scul we
giving a buy here right off this low um
we red back up to the 80s so this Delta
scaler was a nice uh a nice signal as
well um come back
up yeah you get this the Delta scul here
but you know we're trading back up at 82
we're trading back up at at your um
point of control for the day you get a
couple stacked imbalances here yeah okay
now when you have stacked imbalances
okay where do you want to take them
ideally you know you should be taking
them at edges of the day you know value
area highs value area lows highs of the
day highs of lows of the day swing highs
swing lows not in the middle of value
not in the middle of your your days
point of control and you know why
because you know I say this many times
you could have the best indicator in the
world but if you're
trading you in an area of consolidation
and generally your value area is where
you're consolidating uh a market going
sideways or you have absorption you know
trading is being absorbed it's not going
to be a very effective signal I said you
could have the best thing you know I got
this system that works 98% of the time
well 2% of the time it fails often is in
an area where the Market's going
sideways and why you know why why do I
say that is because you know think about
how markets move markets move from value
area to Value area right the purpose of
a market is to find Value and once it
starts rejecting a value area it's going
to move to another value area so when
you're trading in the middle of the
value area that's what the Market's
supposed to be doing it's supposed to be
trading there so the big guys you know
the commercials The Producers the
hedgers can trade can trade uh without
moving the market so um you know if if
you start moving away from the value
area then you know then pay attention
see what's you know if there's signs
that you are going to be moving away
from that value
area so again you know coming into this
uh you know so again that's why I'm not
so
interested even though you know you do
have a overlap stacked selling IM
balance here you know again I do like
that I do like when you get them
overlapped one right after the other um
it is is it is actually quite a very
high percentage trade and it comes off
comes off a bit but again you you're
coming into the FED announcement so you
know you're probably not going to be
really interested in taking any trades
um you know we start to Rally after the
FED announcement this is the Delta surge
again I'm not too too keen on taking
anything around fed announcement um
eventually then you start coming off you
know ratio ratio ratio ratio stacked in
Balance get a little bit of pullback it
just you know again um it's kind of a
goofy day in sense that the market
didn't really react much to the FED but
you know those days happen you mean I
don't know maybe hopefully one day uh
the FED will be abolished by Trump and
uh we'll we'll see what's going to
happen and you know in the evening
session we're trading a bit higher right
now so you know on the daily
chart how did it end
up um well this is today you know we had
this this candle you know we did get the
probe lower we did break out through uh
the lower two days ago but we traded we
ried back up inside um and you know and
and got up here back up to the 82 and
1/2 area uh right now in
the evening session we are trading uh a
bit
higher okay so uh
next let's look at bonds oh take a look
at Five Years
first again you know five years
shortterm I say a short-term interest
rate five years aren't really five years
not a short term but you know the
shorter you go in the curve you know the
more you can see the the price action um
compared to uh compared to the
bonds okay so where am I going back here
o' this a little bit bigger
so you there was a few things right 7:30
I me you did have I didn't I forgot what
numbers came out already but you did
have a number come out 730 you did get a
bounce um you got the
Delta scalper you've got a Divergence
here you again point of control near the
bottom but again you know 7:30 I'm not
too interested in that time um you then
we we start working our way back down
you you get a few things I like this you
know that's why the software draws this
Arrow here it's for a nice shortterm
trade and what it is is you know it's a
buying and balance at the top of the bar
yeah you got a ratio up there as well
and it's good for you know minimum a few
ticks and you do get a little bit of a
move down here it's not the greatest
move
you come down here right at the low of
the day make a new low but right at the
previous low of the day you got point of
controls right at the bottom so I know
there is some volume down there stopping
this move and then here this this move
up was um quite interesting you know you
got this big negative Delta minus 3,000
but look at the bar it's going higher
it's going higher why is because you
have supportive buying in here 5,000
here 2600 2100 even up here 2,800 um you
you could be look you if you're looking
at that
you know again you see a negative Delta
3,000 you think hey we should be trading
lower why are we trading higher it's
usually a nice little it's a sign um
it's a sign to you that you know there
is supportive buying you know there
there's people selling into these bids
but there's just someone standing there
saying you know sell me more sell me
more I'm happy to buy down here and you
know eventually the the sellers lose
interest right because how do you get
the negative Delta right what how do you
get a Delta right I mean if someone
sells into the
bid that's minus one if someone buys the
offer that's plus one so you there's
more selling into this bid than buying
from the offer so when the sellers get
tired the market starts working its way
but up up up
up and you know we get a nice little
rally up there this is the um you get
this High here with a single print okay
um you know is it a big move not really
again it's right at your
uh well at the time I believe it was
right around your point of control a
little bit later we changed it then we
were just sort of going here drifting
sideways drifting sideways we make a new
low you know around the the 9 and a
quarter level um not much in here really
in the orderflow to get excited about um
you then it's you get this stack buying
imbalance here right off the low the low
is this red line at 9 and A4 this is
coming in around 10 and 1/2 to 11 and
you get a ratio in the next bar you know
this is this is how I like to get them
and you got a nice little bit of a move
up here but again it's it was a slow
move you know you're talking this is at
10:40 this bar and all of a sudden it's
1:00 up here again you know so if you're
in a position you don't want to be in
the position right as as the fed's going
to be Mak an announcement you know you'd
get out but honestly you know that's how
how much the market slowed down from 10
until uh 1:00 you can see it's just you
know four bars going nowhere going a
little bit higher um you know before you
know the 1:00 announcement and then you
can see how the market reacted it's kind
of jumping all over the
place again I'm not really interested in
trading around this time that's why I'm
not talking about it people say oh yeah
s these things didn't work out you know
yeah D balance it failed but yeah I say
yeah that failed but it came right back
with you know bullish ratio right on the
low again um Delta scalper up there at
the swing high and you sold off nicely
down into new lows um let's see what
other
goodies there are um I'll look at the
the bonds now if I can find my
chart here it
is okay let's just go back here there
wasn't much happening in the bonds
either this morning honestly um so we
had this low again at 7:30 low with the
actually it came from 7 this morning you
had a high with a Divergence
now this High here it is a high it's
Point control up near the top it's a
ratio bounds low as well but you know
they just [__] all volume um you know at
this time 7 in the morning look at this
range 24 you know this you know here was
uh you know 24 to what was that
15301 you're talking it was that seven a
seven tick range coming in you know
granted it was it was a holiday in
Japan in Hong Kong Japan you know had
this is where the cash bonds Cash Cash
us bonds you know there's cash us bond
market in Japan so when Japan's closed
bonds are really quiet okay and Hong
Kong was also closed and Korea was
closed for what it's worth as well but
um you know the big one is is Japan
being closed and I know when from my own
experience you know when Japan is closed
and Hong Kong is
closed it's really quiet in in in the
markets uh during the Asian session in
the US markets obviously it's quiet in
the Japanese and Asian markets but us
markets especially quiet
um you you don't get much movement so
you know keep that in mind if you're
trading us products when you know during
Japan holidays you're better off just uh
you know watching TV or something but
yeah so we have this High here 7:15 this
morning you know we had this very tight
range okay I mean you is is it
actionable you mean I'd like if I get a
ratio yeah it is I'd like to get a uh
you know some sort of sign now again you
know if you're looking at some sort of
setup you know the O2 setup that I
talked about before which gives you a
lowrisk trade you know this is it um but
unfortunately it got two ticks up there
before it made its move so it would have
stopped you out you know with the one
tick stop up here or sorry one tick
behind the high here you the O2 would be
this high and you're getting short you
know right around here at this level
came back up got two ticks up and then
made the move you know that happens um
ideally I would have liked it to stop at
that level get this ratio and Divergence
and then make the move so anyway if it's
stopped you out you know it's not the
end of the world you got another trade
setup right here you got a Divergence
and a ratio 720 and it makes this move
from the high right down into the low so
you know whatever you lost on this trade
people say oh You2 it failed you suck
yeah I mean that's trading sometimes
trades don't work out um you know get
get over it and then you know the next
one happens you know immediately after
right after you get stopped you got
another sign up here to be getting short
and this time you know you're getting
short we call it 153 even you get all
the way down you know to new lows
15224 and even lower then you get
another you get a Buy Signal this time
you got a Divergence with the ratio gr
it's at 730 I'm not sure you'd be taking
it but then it shoots right back all the
way up to new highs you know so um you
know
so I got nothing else to say about that
um you know people throw stones at me
say oh you know this one failed then
they Overlook you know the times that it
you know this one worked or that one
worked so you know those were the very
interesting trades early um in the bonds
you know this one here you we have the
swing High we got up within a couple
ticks of the high you know this was
after a move um we had hit that high
there sold
off and you know we just you we got this
uh price rejector given a buy there then
you trade up here there's a ratio two
ticks off the high this is the U-turn
given a sell here then you get the Delta
scalper here you know honestly I I
thought this Market could start to sell
off it didn't it just went came right
back with positive
Delta which was stronger than the
previous bar the next bar doe it just
wasn't you know it just wasn't happening
I I expected to sell off here it didn't
happen came right back up within one
tick of the high and then just started
going sideways then going a bit lower
but really I did expect something off
this off this move
here um then you know you come in at
12:00 again you know
it's at this point it's lunchtime and
you know and you got an announcement
coming out you know you're probably not
interested in taking this trade you know
even though it does you know the next
bark go lower you got another bullish
sign here which goes up um this is the
U-turn as well and it sort of works its
way back up so you know if you're taking
this trade you could have most likely
would have scratched it again I probably
would not 1225 definitely would not be
looking to take any trade because you
know if you're going to be holding it
for 30 minutes you're going to be going
into the announcement and the
announcement came off eventually you
know late late in the day we sold off
and in the evening session we're a
little bit
lower all right now let's uh take a look
at beans beans beans
beans again you know I put beans in
there for a number of reasons one I
think beans are a great contract for
trading um and two you know I don't want
to focus you people think that all only
orderflow analysis only works on certain
markets you know beans are pretty much
uncorrelated to bonds or snps even
though you know
generally things move in the same
direction um you know in a bull market
but you know beans can be uh you know'
got completely different um fundamentals
and bonds and uh than equities so 8:30
you know 8:30 is is the reopen um that
coincides with the old floor
hours and you know just taking a look at
some of these things we got again you
know you got a stack buying and balance
831 it's right after the open can you
take it yeah you can you get a little
bit of a move but again I I still
consider that part of the opening
um excuse me the opening period and then
you start rallying here again you get
another stack mind imbalance this time
846 okay right into the high of the day
and you know let me ask you you know
would you rather can the market go
higher yes it can or would you rather be
taking here's a stack selling IM balance
honestly I'd rather be taking the stack
selling balance off at the high than
stack buy imbalance that that's me um in
this case we did we just went sideways
and you know went higher so that would
have stopped you up but you know is at
this High here it's interesting because
you know this bar you know I got a lot
of negative signs up here you I got a
stacked inbalance I got this red arrow
which tells me there's buying in Balance
there I've got a ratio bounds low point
of control at the top um you know there
was a lot of of of bearish signs up
there at that high and you we came back
and we
we didn't go lower um you know and to me
that's a sign as well you know when I'm
staring at something extremely negative
and the market doesn't sell off that
that you know sort of gives me a a sign
that you
know rethink what's going on here and
then what happens is we get up here we
make a new high again you got something
similar this time you got a Divergence
you got the negative Delta you got a
ratio bounds low point of control again
right up near the top and then it comes
right back up so really you I'm seeing
this and we can't sell off you know it's
I'm like wondering what's going on and
we're just trading sideways sideways and
then you start to sell off a bit later
um up here there's nothing really to
tell me is to get short this is the
U-turn here there's also U-turn there um
but again you know the only takeaway is
you know if you're looking up here you
see the volume numbers um you know five
what is that 555 uh 207 here's another
500 400 700 500 you know 300 so I I know
there is some volume up here at these
highs and you know does the market react
off it you know eventually it does sell
off um you come down into the swing low
you got the price rejector you know
given a buy again you know here you've
got the Green Arrow you know with the
selling IM balance down there in a ratio
so you got a few things going on here
and you get a nice little move up this
is the Delta scoper this one doesn't
work and you get back up to these highs
again where you got the heavy volume
this the second time you can see you got
it this even you even have these buying
and balances you know towards the top
this is what I call a split buying and
balance where it's a buying and balance
split over two bars but again it's at
the high of the day um you know do do
you want to keep buying at the high of
the day or would you rather be looking
for a sell and again you know this red
arrow is telling me there's you know
potential a little selling opportunity
we do sell off we do test that high we
don't get past it we test it come back
down again um before rallying back up so
honestly you know I I I do feel that
this Market you know on a sort of a I
hate to say a longer term frame um but
every time we get up to the high I I see
a lot of negative signs up here um you
know even going back up to this 974
level and the market can't really sell
off and then again you get back up to
that 974 975 level very you know it
still looks bearish and you can't really
sell off and in the end you keep making
new highs and you know sort of right now
in the evening session we're trading you
know still around that level so I'll be
curious to see how it plays out um the
next day um on
Thursday now let's
see what other Market here just uh oh
crude
oil crude
[Music]
oil so cud oil you had the inventory
number come out today so there's so I
know there's going to be some activity
in the market so again crude oil you
know 4 in the morning crude oil trades
decent volume during the European
session you know around 4 in the morning
is the old IP floor out 4:00 a.m. when I
say 4 in the morning I'm talking about
Chicago time 400 a.m. Chicago time is is
around on the old you know for your
oldtimers ipe the when Brent crew the
pit hours used to start and surprisingly
that that's still when you get a lot of
volume you know when when volume really
picks up um but anyway you've got you
know 4:00 you got this high in the crude
oil and then you know immediately
afterward you get the uh Delta scalper
given a nice sell it's a nice little
move down um lower lower lower um and
then you get down here you have yeah you
have stacked inbalance but it's going
into the low I mean you do get a little
something out of it start rallying back
up Delta scalper giv a little bit of a
buy there um again then you start coming
into these lows here boom you make a new
low ratio bounds low the
Divergence in the next bar you get a uh
buying imbalance H sorry Delta scalper
you know it doesn't it it just the bar
comes up but it's a it's a red bar so
you know are you interested in taking it
just like here you have the Delta surge
see the Delta increasing but the price
action of the bars are still lower again
you know if you're looking to be taking
buys you should be taking buys on
candles that are green you know candles
that are closing higher than where they
opened you get down a the low this is a
um this is the Volos uh U-turn down here
on the low for finding reversals um you
know just really quick is it any good
well this one didn't really work this
one didn't work
um else was there there was there was
there was a few more like this one
worked here I don't think this was one
but um you can see it works just it's
decent at finding reversals so anyway
you know 9:30 inventory numbers come out
that's why you see this Market
uh in a in a fast Market condition you
know you're you're literally talking
moves from you know this is 40
4800 down to uh 47 you know 46 all
within 15 seconds um you know let this
Market calm down a bit before you know
really putting on your thinking cap for
analysis you know then we get to this
bar here 943 this was
interesting big negative Delta 1,200 you
know it's it's your biggest negative
Delta of the morning I
believe and you know it just runs into
this thing you know point of control
though is up in the middle of the bar
but there's some decent volume down here
515 377 281 you got a couple selling IM
balances down there
um and you do have the Delta surge
kicking off but again it's Delta surge
going into the low and it's Delta surge
sell and you have the bar that's closing
higher not going to be very wise to be
taking a sell there um I I got a lot
more bullish things going on here than
than anything else and the market shoots
up you know shoots up uh you know quite
nicely from this low at around the the
the you know 40s all the way up into the
70s um comes off
again again you know talking about
taking Delta surge know this is it's
actually the Delta surge here and
the Delta scalper given buys here um I
know this is a Delta surch by looking at
the numbers and I know this is the price
Delta scalper just by also looking at
the numbers but I can see the colors
here it look doesn't look blue as per
normal because it's blue and green mixed
together um and it's given a nice little
buy here and it just shoots straight up
here again that's what I talk about you
know if you're taking you know
signals you know buy signals the bar
should be green right not uh you know
like taking the sell signal with a green
bar you should be taking a sell signal
with a red bar just as you're taking buy
signals with with green bars you know
bars that close higher I and mean what's
the point of taking a buy if the bar
itself that's giving you the
signal doesn't even close higher so um
anyway we shoot up quite nicely from
here from this uh 50 Area all the way up
into again you know it didn't get up to
4,800 but it got up to you know 48 47
you know 80s 4790s before you know
giving a sign this is the price
rejector coming off again it's only 10:
in the morning so it's it's quite a busy
morning in in the crude um
um again we get this nice little rally
here then again you know this is
the Delta scoer but it's given a it's
given a buy okay it's a green candle
okay you know i' bite didn't work it
just came right back out and stopped you
out um you know that's
life oh I took the trade I had a losing
trade you know it sucks well yeah it's a
numbers game you know it's like dating
you know you got to date different women
before you find the one so you know what
can you do it's not everybody has the
the fortune of uh you know Finding their
wife or finding their spouse on on their
first
date um you know Del this is the price
for uh Delta scaler again gives a sell
it does uh does sell off a little bit
before you get a bullish signal here
with this um U-turn here we rally
up get up here aggressive buying coming
in here again you know we're making
another run up at 4,800 so you know
people I think are are getting a little
bit antsy thinking hey we got to get
this move up to 48 bucks and go higher
that's why you see these aggressives and
then it starts selling off again and so
all these people that were buying it
aggressively here are looking to sell
you know they realize hey you know what
we're not going to get up to 48 bucks
these buyers turn Sellers and it starts
selling off here you got the uh Delta
scalper giving a signal here you got the
Delta surge giving a signal there then
it sort of hits this low area back down
into uh you know 4760 you know it's a
decent move it's you know from 4780 down
and then again you know one o00 fed
announcement you know and it is going to
affect oil whether you like to admit it
or not um you then the
markets go sideways for a while before
uh shooting back up here um you know
1:00 and you know again you know 130
it's just you're getting you know some
bullish and bearish sign you know
bearish sign bearish sign you get
there's one bullish in here this is the
price Delta scalper you got the Stacked
in balance again you know the one nice
thing about the Stacked imbalances you
got the ratio afterwards I always say
you know look for the Stacked imbalances
with the ratio afterwards um you didn't
get much of a move just kind of you know
sideways a little bit lower this is the
uh Delta scalper that gave a buy it
didn't work out but you know it came
right back so you know if you're short
from here you run into this bar here it
gives you a buy then you get a bearish
signal here followed up with another
bearish signal here and you can see the
market unfortunately you got Point these
point of controls all just sort of
lining up before you make the move lower
but you know honestly by 3:00 you're not
going to be looking to still be trading
crude oil especially after how much
activity there was um earlier that day
you're at this point you're a bit
exhausted in from looking at
crude so any you know it's this I'm not
going to talk about Euro currency
because well [__] it I'll talk about
eurocurrency I didn't want to say I to
talk about it but um you know just the I
try to keep these videos around 30
minutes and I'm already over 30 minutes
but um what the hell
again you know this is 1:00 this is when
the FED announcement came out you can
see the only Market that didn't budge
was was really the the equity Market um
and you know I I really think it's I
said there's there's just so much on the
equity Traders plates as far as
uh things coming out this week that you
know maybe they're just they're just
waiting to see you know I mean with they
don't really want to go all in on
anything until they got a better grasp
of uh what the hell is going on with uh
this
President and obviously the elections in
in Europe because you know even JP
Morgan is talking now about moving um
you know 4,000 staff out of London and
you know these other banks are also
talking about moving staff out of London
um sort of makes me still wish I was
working at JP Morgan or in London then
i' if probably get a nice package but
actually you know JP Morgan's got a lot
cheaper over the
years you know unless you're like a
super senior executive you don't get the
big xat packages anymore they they
localize you and just pay you local
rates um you know the the days of the
high-flying expat are are mostly over
for for most people I mean you know some
companies yeah they still give it but uh
in general most companies nowadays
especially JP Morgan everyone thinks oh
JP Morgan Bank so rich no they're
[__] cheap [__]
um you know I said unless you're a super
senior executive then uh you know they
just [__] lowball you you think you
know just be happy to have a job and
you're working at in such a great place
like JP Morgan you have the name on your
resume you know [__] that you know um
but anyway uh I digress it's my my
little bit of a rant today so anyway um
your currency you'll take a look at some
from 7:00 I people say oh you're looking
from 7 just because you have signal
there okay well [__] you I'll go back
here and you know going back to 4 in the
morning again you know it did have a
decent range um you know from 10961 and
a half down to 31 so about a 30 point
range in the in the euro currency coming
in to around 4 in the morning you get
these divergences here here um you know
but no
ratios again you do have this Delta
scalper given a buy here but you know
it's on a red bar I'm not interested you
get it a little bit later here it's a
green bar okay but you know it's still
hasn't necessarily found its low yet you
do come down here make a new low um it's
just going sideways at this point I mean
compared to compare this Market to the
other markets honestly and yeah overall
this euro currency did have movement the
other markets weren't doing anything so
I know people will say well I want to
trade the market that's moving and
they'll look at the euro currency but
you know it's a false trap um markets in
general should be moving all markets you
know rather than you know bonds very
tight range 5 years tight Range s P
tight range um you know don't don't
think all of a sudden I found the one
market where things are moving I'm going
to trade that
no yeah it's going to be directional
list also and what I mean by directional
list is not a whole lot of Trades um
sorry not a whole lot of Trends so
anyway coming into the US hours where
you would expect things to pick up and
they
do and you rally back up to almost you
know almost 50 get up to 48 start coming
off Delta scalper giving a sell there it
comes off a little bit rallies back back
up you know again you know if if you're
not tring your stop you probably would
have been stopped out there honestly um
again then you get this bullish signal
here you got this Arrow here you got a
ratio you got this imbalance here and it
can't muster anything just sort of go
sideways on you and it's just going
sideways most of the morning um you know
this is 8:46 here and look at this from
you know
10935 basically the 10948 is is your
range for about 2 hours this morning an
hour and a half do make new 9:00 um PMI
I believe came out around 9 UM you get a
little bit of a rally get up here point
of control up near the top okay sell off
price rejector you start rallying back
up um you know I said I didn't really
want to talk about this cuz there really
wasn't that much you know juicy things
to talk about but you know still um you
you hit the swing High you come off
again you start getting alternating s
signals you know bearish bullish bearish
which is also a sign of quiet Market but
again it's happening right before 1:00
you know this is 12 you know4 after 12
12:45 30 minutes and I I know it's it's
it's in this holding pattern until the
fomc announcement comes out and you know
this Market
went you got a lot of activity as well
in this market I said you know you
didn't get much in the uh equities but
again you know just give you an idea how
fast it's moving you know the move
started about a minute actually before
the FMC came out but you know 1:00 here
you're trading you know 38 you trade all
the way down to 28 all the way back up
to 48 and you can just see how fast it
is you know it's 1 13 O and 1 second 4
seconds 7 Seconds 12 seconds 15 18 23 31
etc etc it's it's it's moving pretty
fast
there and you know just again you know
we're still moving in this fast Market
this Market moved much quicker than the
um
then the equities so you're coming down
you know into these lows here one just
after 1:00 110 you got a price rejector
you've got
the this is the price rejector you got
the Delta scal for given buys and it
just gets Slamm back down into new lows
then down here you got the Delta surge
gives another buy slam back down into
lows you know here's price uh Delta
scalper but it's on a red
bar again here you just getting slammed
into these lows so again it's still
again it's after 1:00 again you know if
there's certain days of the month then
to not be trading you know days honestly
that I I stay away from you know fomc
days is one um nonfarm payrolls is
another obviously elections yeah you can
make shitloads of money if you're
positioned right um on those days but
you could also lose a bunch of money on
on days like that that you're wrong so
is it worth it you ask yourself you know
I know my Trading
it's just better to for me to to stay on
the side you know you don't have to
trade every single day I'd rather trade
when everyone talks about having an edge
in the market you know and you know I'd
rather trade under normal conditions
where I have an edge rather than
volatile conditions where you know I may
have an edge but the market is moving
too fast to take advantage of
it so anyway uh that is it for today so
thanks for watching this to learn more
about the orl trading and software that
I use in this presentation visit
orderflows